Okay, I think we're going.
All right.
Hello.
I am very happy today to be
talking to Bruce Perens, who is
one of the founders of the Open
Source movement and who created
the 'open source' definition.
You know, it's impossible to
catalog all of Bruce's
achievements in a short
introduction and to most in the
open source world, he doesn't need
any introduction.
But I'll mention a couple of
things.
He's the creator of BusyBox, which
is a key software utility for
Linux system that everybody uses
all the time, and he was a key
developer at Pixar, helping to
create the technology of 3D
animated feature films.
Bruce, welcome to FOSSDA!
Well, thank you very much,
Heather.
So glad that you're willing to
take the time to talk to me today.
So, I'd like to know what got you
involved in open source?
How'd you decide to get involved
in/create this movement of open
source?
Well, obviously, I'm standing on
the shoulders of giants because
the work of Richard Stallman
preceeded mine, and the basic
concepts of open source are those
created by Richard for free
software.
What we did with open source was
create a marketing program for the
free software concept which would
reach different people.
So, Richard's approach was very
well suited for programmers, but
it depended on the apriori
understanding of the usefulness of
software freedom.
And our approach was more based on
just having a big collection of
software that you could build,
whether it was a business or any
project that you wanted to, you
could build these upon, you could
share the development of the
software and my feeling personally
was that the philosophy would come
later for a lot of the people who
participated.
And so, obviously, we were
successful beyond our wildest
dreams.
We took over, essentially, the
software industry.
Open source is everywhere.
Whether you understand it or not,
you encounter it in your life all
day.
And so, that has been very
fulfilling.
We did not achieve all of our
goals.
Actually, I would have liked it if
people did appreciate the need for
software freedom, which is
something that is becoming more
meaningful today, especially in
the context of privacy and people
seeing the large web companies, as
sort of privacy eating giants,
don't really have your best
interest in mind.
And open source, though very
successful, I think, has evolved a
extremely capable open source,
exploitation industry.
So, I'm not quite so happy about
that, I actually am working on
solutions.
Well, so, tell me at the very
beginning - and by the way, I kind
of know some of the answer to this
because you and I have known each
other for a long time but - Yeah
but we have an audience so let's
conquer that!
Yeah, right!
How did you actually get involved
in the development of open source?
What was the motivation for doing
that in the first place?
Well, I had been a Unix systems
programmer since 1981 and that was
at the lab that was the
predecessor of Pixar.
It was at New York Tech, a
otherwise not-very-memorable
college, that had the computer
graphics laboratory - almost a
hobby of the chancellor of this
college, the late Alexander Schure
- and we were creating 3D feature
character animation in that
laboratory.
A lot of the people went on to
Pixar, also many other places -
Disney, Dreamworks, all over.
And so, I was into Unix and
eventually went to work for Pixar.
And one day, I actually sat across
from Steve Jobs' office, not
because I was important, I think
they wanted to keep an eye on me.
And so, one day, Steve made his
peace with Bill Gates and where
there had been a NeXT workstation
on Steve's desk, there was now a
Windows laptop and for a time at
Pixar, Steve felt that computing
would just all turn to Microsoft
Windows and I have asserted down
on that.
I didn't actually think of it as a
very capable system, especially at
the time because Microsoft didn't
have competition that would give
it a strong quality incentive like
they have now.
And so, Linux started to come
along because of a number of
factors.
The Canoe project had developed
all of what we call runtime.
So all of the programs that would
run on it, and the libraries for
the most part were a product of
the Canoe project - but the Canoe
project was not successful in
developing a kernel, which is the
part that connects the hardware
and the software - and so, Linus
Torvalds came along and made a
successful kernel.
At the start it didn't have
networking, you know, people don't
remember the Linux didn't actually
work on the net successfully for
quite a while and people started
to create Linux distributions and
there were a number of for-profit
ones, most of which no one has
ever heard of today.
And Ian Murdock saw this happening
and said, well, let's create a
non-profit one and he created
Debian which most people actually
know through Ubuntu today and I
joined, I guess, there must have
been 50 people on the whole
project at the time, and
eventually became the Debian
project leader.
Ian went on to other things and
took the project and did something
that no one knew was possible at
that time, which was that Ian had
made all of the core of the
project, everything that it needed
to boot and run and install
packages, had been produced by
Ian.
And I took it and obviously didn't
have the time to work on all of
these packages and fanned them out
to 50 people who I only knew from
email correspondence on the net.
I was a Debian project leader, I
had never actually met another
Debian developer, and fanned it
out.
And these 50 people who also did
not physically know each other
combined to create a working,
running, operating system.
And obviously, the software was
very modular and that certainly
helped us get away with that but
also the fact that open source let
us all sort of look over each
other's shoulders and help each
other was very useful as well.
So all of these people who had no
common employer, who hadn't met at
that time, and who really only had
their own private goals driving
this - I think, at that point,
none of them were actually doing
this for their employer - combined
to create a working operating
system that among other things,
flew on the space shuttle
controlling an experiment, was
very, very successful.
And most of the work that we did
at that time survives in the Linux
system that you are using today,
some of it in your Android
telephones.
Because I wrote BusyBox, BusyBox
was the installer.
The whole idea of BusyBox is it's
all of the commands that you might
need to install an operating
system on a computer made smaller
so that they all would fit on a
floppy disk.
Okay, that's how far back this
goes.
We had those three-and-a-half inch
plastic floppy disks and the
kernel fit on one and all of the
runtime and BusyBox fit on the
second one.
And so, you would boot your system
using these two floppy disks and
then you would be able to put a CD
in the CD drive and install the
entire distribution from it.
I don't think we even had bootable
CD at that point.
And if you didn't have a CD, we
also had a way to make rather
large collection of floppy disks,
and you would also just keep
feeding floppies into your
computer until you had a system
installed.
You know, going back this far, I
think I had 240 megabyte hard
drives on the computer I was using
for development.
So, thats actually practical to
feed this all with that amount of
floppies, and this worked!
And I, actually, for all of the
work that other people have done
upon it and all of the legal
issues, which later popped up, I
worked on BusyBox for an entire
month and I never touched it
again.
I created about 35 programs in
that month and subsequent to that,
it was adopted by a series of
other programmers who made
tremendous improvements to it, but
I actually checked and my code is
still in it.
And I used the GPL license, and
the GPL license is a
share-and-share-alike license and
thus, if you made improvements to
this program, you had to share the
improvement.
So my original investment of a
month of evenings I should have
been spending with my wife,
really, was tremendously,
tremendously expanded by the
subsequent work of all of these
people which they did under the
GPL license contribute when in
some cases the incentive for them
would have been to keep their
modifications private.
So we had two embedded systems-
companies that decided to make
embedded Linux and deal it to a
number of commercial companies
that were putting it on various
kinds of hardware.
And one of them was Linio and I
don't even remember the name of
the other now.
And those companies achieved a six
months time to market lead by
using my software rather than
creating their own and this was in
terms of- it might have taken some
of their guys that long to add all
of the software and make it all
work.
And so they built on my software
and the software became much much
larger, got up above a hundred and
thirty commands.
So bigger than a floppy disk?
Yeah and essentially a small but
capable command line system that
you could do many different things
with.
And so, that system became part of
a lot of Android telephones, of
part of wireless access points, if
you use- well, the open source
project OpenWrt uses it.
Then many commercial, wireless
access point designs are derived
from that.
For example, there are very many
embedded devices for the most
mundane uses - aquarium
temperature controllers that all
have this software in them, and
webcams, all kinds of things.
And so, for something that I spent
a month upon, I did not ever
receive financial compensation
directly from it, but it has tens
and hundreds of millions of users.
All right.
Users who don't necessarily even
know that it exists but there is
some pride in that, just as an
artist likes to have their
paintings appreciated, a
programmer likes to have lots of
users and lots of things happening
with their software.
And today, I know that a jet plane
does not fly without using BusyBox
and you don't, you probably don't
wake up and get into your day
without using BusyBox.
And so, that's really fun and it
was worth that months of evenings
and Valerie and I are still
together even though I probably
neglected her for that whole
month.
And so, we didn't receive direct
payment for this, but I did
receive a great deal of notoriety
which has led to a lot of other
opportunities.
One of the most fun was I was in a
commercial for IBM Linux after
they bought Red Hat.
I think this was actually a
mistake that the casting person
cast me and then I think there was
quite a to-do within IBM because
they would have vastly preferred
to cast someone from Red Hat, but
I ended up being the face of Linux
for IBM for a good eight months
and actually IBM's conference that
year.
They opened with an extended video
from the commercial.
So, the conference opens and the
very first thing that people see
is my face and I got fifty
thousand dollars for a couple
hours work.
You know, Hollywood is that way
when you're successful and I'm
sure it's very, very difficult
when you're not.
And so that was one of the things
but I've had most of my employment
and consulting opportunities are
connected to this work that I did
- oh gee, now it's coming up on 30
years ago - and so that's just
been great fun.
Obviously, I have some regrets
over the way that things have come
out, but it's been incredibly more
successful than anyone could have
ever asked so those things are
very tempered.
So, that's probably enough for one
question.
Well, that's really great.
Thank you.
I mean, you were doing this all
during the time you were still
working at Pixar, isn't that
right?
Yeah, I was working at Pixar and,
as I said, I worked for Steve
Jobs.
Not directly, I had managers.
There was Ed Catmull, the CEO, who
now, I guess, is a CEO of Disney,
if he's still there.
And I was a Systems Programmer for
Imaging for the most part so I
invented image composing language
and did a great deal of work for
them.
But one of the things I noticed
was that, for the most part, my
work for Pixar, all end of life
while I was still working there,
was replaced with something else.
And of course, when you make
software for a movie, we go on to
the next movie and we don't always
use the same software.
And, so, during this time, Pixar
made their IPO, which was very
useful because I had enough money
from the IPO to pay off my
mortgage and I could be a flake
because unlike everybody else in
Silicon Valley, I didn't have this
incredible mortgage that I would
take many, many years to pay off.
And so, I could work full-time on
open source and, you know, see
where the money came in, which it
usually did.
And so, I remember at the time
someone saying to me "well, Pixar
is having its IPO and you have Toy
Story coming out, and isn't this
wonderful?" And at the time, the
space shuttle had just launched
with Debian Linux and the
biosciences project on it and I
said well, you know, it's cool to
have a movie in theaters and to
have an IPO that's being very
successful but my hobby project is
orbiting in space and that's
actually more fulfilling to me.
And I remember actually finding
out that this would happen.
The way it happened was, someone
wrote to me, someone who I did not
know, and I was at my desk at
Pixar and and said, can I boot
Debian on a serial console?
And I had never done this because
I had only developed on desktops
that had VGA cards at the time,
you know, lower resolution
graphical displays.
And I said, well, that's
interesting and I have on my desk
here at Pixar, would I need to
test that?
So, I took 15 minutes from Pixar,
and I tested it and took another
15 minutes and documented my
changes back to back out so I
could get back to my work at Pixar
and wrote back to the Sky
Sebastian Kuznetsky and said
here's what you need to do.
And he wrote back and said that
works great, this is going on the
next space shuttle.
And so, you know, imagine me at my
desk at Pixar with my jaw now
unhinged and on the floor
somewhere and I got up and I
walked all around the building
looking for someone to tell this
to.
And the only person who understood
about Linux was Loren Carpenter, a
very famous computer graphic
person, and Loren was working from
home that day so that there was no
one at Pixar I could tell this to
who would have a clue of what was
happening and not think I was
crazy.
And that kind of decided me that
Pixar wasn't really my future.
And there had been other things
they had actually restarted
vesting from zero and I'd been
there for eight years, which was
kind of annoying.
And so I, at that point, you know,
said to myself, I'm going to have
to work for this company 12 years
to be vested in my stock.
And Pixar had actually gone
bankrupt once or twice on the way
to success and Steve had funded
them out of pocket.
His advisor, his financial
advisor, told him, you know, you
probably shouldn't do this again,
but he gave us another chance.
And so, essentially, the day after
I was fully vested after 12 years
at Pixar, I left and went to work
for my first venture capital
operation was called Linux Capital
group and it was not successful;
I'm in another unsuccessful one
today.
And so, I worked for them for a
while and that did not work out
and then I left that company
essentially so that they would not
have to pay me and they'd be able
to keep Progeny Linux systems,
which was Ian's company, afloat.
That worked for 7 years, but they
eventually closed that one, too.
And so, I went to work for
Hewlett-Packard as Senior Global
Strategist of Linux and Open
Source and that was all because of
the notoriety that I had
accumulated as, you know, an open
source spokesperson and developer.
So, I remember leaving Pixar and
walked into Steve's office and,
you know, there were a lot of
stories about Steve.
Steve was never nasty to me and
probably because I got there
first.
I was a pretty obnoxious guy, you
know, still am in many ways, and I
was very aggressive.
And so I think that Steve and I
were sort of on the same
wavelength in that regard.
And so I walked in and he knew I
was leaving and I said "You still
don't believe in this Linux stuff"
and Steve, you know, Mr. Ego, said
to me "Well, I've been involved in
creating two of the three great
operating systems" - and by that,
he meant, Mac OS and NeXTSTEP -
"and all of them took a
billion-dollar laboratory and I
don't think that you can get over
the hump because you don't have
the billion-dollar laboratory".
And so, you know, shook Steve's
hand, said goodbye.
Never actually communicated with
Steve, again.
I sent him one or two emails and
never got a reply.
He wasn't one to talk to
ex-employees.
And a year later though, Steve got
on stage at Macworld and
introduced the Safari browser.
And the Safari browser was
graphical web browser based on the
KDE Open Source Graphics Project.
So the point there was that
graphics developed by open source
had already exceeded what they
could do inside Apple.
And that Apple was leveraging upon
it in order to get a leg up on the
web browser development, which
they were kind of behind on at
that point, and if you ask me,
they're still behind today.
And so, Steve stood on the stage
at Macworld in front of a huge
slide saying "Open Source, We Love
It" and although Steve never
acknowledged it, I won that
argument.
Come on, Heather!
Well, that's one of those things
like 'revenge is a dish best
served cold', something like that.
Not exactly revenge, but
everybody, I guess, comes around
to open source eventually.
It's just a matter of how long it
takes them to do that, right?
Ah. Yeah, I mean, back then was
when Craig Mundie had said Linux
is a virus, it will steal your
intellectual property.
And today, obviously, Microsoft is
part of the open-source
exploitation industry.
They're not just using it for
their health but they are
participants in open source to a
degree that no one at Microsoft or
outside would have believed when
this all started.
And that's what really gets me is,
so many things have happened that
no one would have believed.
And mostly because the economics,
though real, was not intuitive.
And so, if I had said to you, I'm
going to get together with my
friends who I've never met on the
internet and develop an
encyclopedia and it's going to put
Encyclopedia Britannica out of
business so far that they don't
even make the printed version
anymore, you would have said
"You're on drugs, Bruce".
And, you know, if I'd said I'm
going to make an operating system
that essentially takes over the
industry, they would have said the
same thing and all of these
happened.
And without boring people to
tears, there's a paper I wrote
about this called "The Emerging
Economic Paradigm of Open Source"
and it's 15 years old and still
current, and if you want to
understand the economics, read
that.
Yeah, it's really- it's been an
amazing journey for everybody.
I think that maybe for you, more
than most people.
You know, I'd like to ask a little
bit more about like, what what was
it like collaborating with 50
people you didn't know?
I mean, you said that was
considered impossible at the time.
Now, I think, people probably
almost take it as a given?
I'd like to know your thoughts
about how how that came about, why
it worked, some cases where it
didn't work - whatever you'd like
to talk about about sort of the
community aspect of it.
Um, I think that the software
collaboration was very successful.
A lot of the organizational
efforts were not.
For example, during this time, I
drove the creation of software in
the public interest, non-profit
that's still very active in
supporting open source projects,
and there was vast distrust among
the Debian developers of software
in the public interest.
And I think that it would have
been legally advantageous for the
developers to be working on behalf
of this non-profit which would
actually take up the liability
because they were individuals, and
if they got sued, they were out of
the game.
And software in the public
interest would probably have been
able if it were sued to get help
from kind people like you.
And so, this was vastly distrusted
by the developers and, you know,
it was a non-profit.
I wasn't about to take the money
and pocket it or even pay myself.
So the reasons for it really
escape me.
So there were failures like that,
but in general, if you were just
making software, everybody was
willing to give a hand in making
software and at that time, I think
email communication felt natural
to us.
And there's actually an
interesting but somewhat creepy
aspect of it, which is, we don't
really like to admit that a great
many of us programmers are on the
spectrum, and are very capable and
had very successful lives, but may
have been a little debilitated
with regard to personal
interaction.
And many of these people are
actually more comfortable
collaborating with the community
entirely textually, not looking at
their faces, not having to parse
their voice tone.
And to some degree, that may have
actually helped us and it's
actually sad that for the most
part those people cannot
collaborate in that way any longer
that the technology is improved to
the point that you and I are
looking at each other's faces
again, where we at the time, would
not have heard each other's voice
and would not have seen each
other.
Yeah, I think that's very
interesting that there's a kind of
temporal disconnect and personal
disconnect that's possible in
these asynchronous, like,
development platforms and so forth
that work very well for some
people.
Yeah, and also, if you're one of
these programmers who has some
social issues, computing is a very
comfortable environment for you
because your computer doesn't
dislike you and not work with you
because it doesn't like your face.
Your program runs if it's correct,
and it doesn't run until it's
correct.
And so these were the, that was
also something that was very
comfortable for the kind of person
who really does like to stay in
their cube and code, and, you
know, do their work with the world
that way.
Now, I sort of bridged both of
those worlds.
I think people know this by now, I
am not neurotypical.
And so I have some of those
issues, but I'm also very, very
well trained.
While I think it might have been
better at the time to put me in
speech therapy, my schools didn't
have that.
So they just put me in rhetoric
class every year.
And so, I had, you know,
practically an hour of public
speech practice every day, for
perhaps a decade of my life, and
came out of this a really good
public speaker and was able to
evangelize this stuff where other
people might not have.
And, in fact, I actually have the
opposite of the fear of public
speaking.
I have a fear of being in
audiences because I will feel so
strongly about a subject that I'll
be tempted to argue with the
speaker, and actually have.
So I'm actually more comfortable
if I'm up there talking and that
probably doesn't say good things
about me.
Well, you certainly have been a
beloved advocate for all these
years and I think it's very
interesting that some of that came
out of dealing with a challenge,
you know, but you you were able to
turn it to something that
benefitted everyone.
An actual, actual physical
handicap.
I cound not talk clearly, I could
not move the way other people
moved.
And, you know, these things, you
can, sometimes, age out of them,
but it was a great part of what
made me, what I am.
Well, that's really great.
So anything else you'd like to
share before we wrap up?
This has been a fascinating
conversation and even though I've
known you for a long time, always
really like hearing about your
story over again, or, you know, or
different aspects of it.
Anything else you'd like to share
before we stop?
Well, I think that this is a kind
of success that other people don't
always achieve and I would
encourage everyone to follow their
dreams, work on what you love to
the extent that you can.
I mean, don't make your family
broke.
But sometimes, you can achieve
these things and internet
collaboration has made so much
more of this possible.
And that was something that I
really touched upon it.
That time, no one understood all
of the implications that there
were projects, that at the time,
people just would have been
considered nuts for working on.
But when you have 50 nuts who
believe the same as you on the
internet, you're more powerful
than any startup company.
And so, today you can achieve
incredible things and I would
encourage everyone to give that a
try.
See if they can do it.
That's great.
Well, thanks so much, Bruce.
I really appreciate your talking
to me today and contributing this
to FOSSDA.
Thanks very much, Heather.
Okay, bye bye.
Bye Bye!